as we found out last week Dragon Ball's
filler is a magical experience that
drags you from the depths of predictable
tedium to the most preposterously
ambitious and sometimes we even get some
good stuff thrown in there too last week
I was tasked with watching over 8 hours
of classic Dragon Ball's filler material
it was tough however I did mention that
Dragon Ball Z's filler was much longer
how much longer you ask 1 Hour 2 hours
maybe 15 hours unlike the stuff I got to
watch last week I've actually seen all
of this already I think though not in
roughly 20 years so this will be as much
a surprise for you guys as it will be
for me no doubt so strap in for some
garlic some bad driving lessons and some
snake way Shenanigans because today
we're finishing the filler of Dragon
Ball in
[Music]
style if you didn't watch my last video
you should you monster but also let me
remind you what we're considering filler
in this video for the sake of my sanity
and time we will not be covering drawn
out extensions in Canon episodes so no
lengthy staredowns or Bulma chasing a
frog around while Goku punches Frieza
we're looking for proper Standalone
episodes and mini arcs and with that
I'll be looking to see whether said
filler arcs and episodes will do one of
two things number one will they
Implement their own creativity without
getting in the way of the Cannon story
or number two will they avoid conflict
with the main story so much so that they
just end up being criminally boring
there's a there's a little great area in
there and that's where you operate
granted this is an almost impossible
Balancing Act to pull off effectively
but hey we got some diamonds last week
and like I said that time I'm expecting
most of this to be honor dog iffy at
best so if we can come away from this
video with one or two gems then I'll
consider it a roaring success let's do
this preparing for the saans being a
robot I will never die and I will never
be able to experience this sweet release
of death The World Is A Lie existence is
a lie there is only pain in darkness
Beyond this point these were the first
pieces of filler I ever engaged with in
my life at the annoying age of 9 years
old I saw this collection of episodes
for the very first time and outside of
the snake way Stu with Goku I honestly
had little interest so you might be
shocked to find out that upon revisit I
actually enjoyed myself quite a bit more
than I thought I would with this
material with Nine episodes to explore
this filler Arc places a microscope over
the very training that was skipped over
with the likes of Gohan the gang at the
lookout the journey Goku undertakes on
his way to King Kai and the saans even
get their own crappy little segment can
you guess which one of those four
stories I didn't like it certainly has
its ups and downs but what this material
offered Gohan I thought was quite great
all things considered with plenty of
subtle writings symbolism and lessons
for the young man to contend with as he
tries to survive in the Wilds of Earth
grappling with monsters hunger and his
growing sense of moral obligation let's
take a look at Gohan's training hey
there have you heard about my robot
friend he's metal and small and doesn't
judge me at all he's a cyber wi bundle
of joy my robot
friend towards the beginning of my
obnoxiously long review of Dragon Ball Z
saian Saga I noted that it appeared
clear Toriyama didn't want fans to
consider Gohan anything other than
Goku's opposite fearful polite Beyond
his years and generally helpless he
demonstrated all the attributes his
father never exhibited in the manga the
first steps away from this approach are
dealt with through offscreen training
and hardship to bring him up to power
with the rest of the Gang This is of
course to create a sense that Gohan is
now ready and while that works
remarkably well in the manga I think a
lot of the material added to Gohan story
here offers a wonderfully natural and
emotional progression for us to follow
as an alternative a Coming of Age story
with a beginning middle and surprisingly
enough an end to but while is cool
seeing Gohan doing all of these next
level cool cool things sometimes you
just want to be able to do the cool
things yourself well that's what video
games are for you know those mad Lads
over at ho yse who may gench an impact
that basically broke the internet well
they've only gone on to make another
amazing game introducing hunai star rail
I know I know you've probably heard all
about how great it is at this point but
this multiplatform space hopping
Adventure just got a big old update and
it's a great time to jump in the first
of the two brand new characters in this
update is jingu this badass blindfolded
has a little secret under there those
red eyes are cold as ice and godamn does
she deal some punishing damage coming up
at the end of the month are the dynamic
duo topaz and numby this cute little imp
girl might look Meek but she's a smart
business woman and if you cross her
she'll summon numby to kick your ass
this is all part of hanon Kai's 1.4
update that jumps back into the depths
of bog with an all new Story featuring
two new maps and the return of zela if
you log in for 7 days you can get 10 10
star rail special passes for free and
that's a great way of pulling these new
characters but there's actually more to
it than that the update kicks off the
ethereum wars where you can pit your
favorite monsters against one another
there's so much variety that really
makes for a great experience for both
new and existing players now if that
sounds good then be sure to check out
the links below to download honai Star
rail today and if you use my promo code
on the screen right now you get 50 free
stellar Jades once again my link is in
the description and it's entirely
free episode 9 kicks things off as we
see Gohan accidentally fall into a
cavern where he discovers an old robot
what's wonderful about this episode to
me is its measured and subtle dialogue
written by katsuyuki Sumi Sawa and a to
keep in mind going forward he
establishes the pattern by which Gohan
reluctantly but consistently marches
down henceforth activating the robot out
of fear Gohan cries out for safety food
emotional support support and answers to
all of his problems long before thinking
to ask the robot about himself this is
terrific characterization and paints
Gohan as a total self-obsessed crybaby
as all small children mostly are It's a
Wonderful starting point from which to
measure his progression against not just
in this episode but the rest of this
minarch when the robot responds Gohan
develops a fondness for it having not
left the cavern out of fear before what
keeps him there now is his desire to
find a solution that allows his new
robot friend to get out of there with
him tragically the room they reside
within starts to fall apart and with the
roof crashing down around them in order
to save Gohan's life the robot is forced
to throw him out the only Gap to safety
against his will all the young boy can
do then is watches his friend Fades from
the world Gohan is left crying and alone
to feel sorry for himself once again
it's a remarkably somber scene one that
is capped off by Gohan smiling through
his tears knowing that he couldn't save
his friend or himself episode 10 builds
off of these established foundations
this time we're not greeted by a crying
child an apprehensive and skittish child
sure but nowhere near the catastrophy of
cribbing we endured in episodes prior
and symbolically this episode is a
juggernaut it's established early on
that Gohan is applying lessons his
father taught him in order to survive in
the wild the through line of this
episode is this medicinal patch he fixes
for both himself and his injured
dinosaur friend that he discovers later
on Goan even Echoes his father's own
words to this dinosaur it's a cute
dialogue call back but it also pulls
double duty insinuating that Gohan is
trying and in some way succeeding in
being more like his father and while
he's still faking it until he makes it
he's clearly making progress here and
there's tons of visual symbolism all
over this episode to reinforce that
point Gohan is seen jumping from Branch
to Branch like Goku dealing with animals
he otherwise would never have meddled
with before like Goku does catching fish
jumping from Great Heights or even
demonstrating great strength on purpose
where the first few chapters of Dragon
Ball Z's manga demonstrated how
different Gohan was this episode shows
us that he might be more like his father
than we thought and even he thought that
is only for our expectations to then be
subverted once again at this episode's
closing unable to protect his friend
from the dangers of this world he wakes
up to find nothing left of him once
again Gohan is forced to contend with
the cruelty of this world and how
important it is for him to have the
strength to protect those he cares for
He walks off once again towards his
future alone but what makes this segment
this training Arc that he undergoes so
compelling to me is that throughout the
material I've discussed Gohan's goal has
remained the same it hasn't been to
train or toughen himself up that's been
Piccolo's goal for him for Gohan it has
been instead to make his own way back to
his mother to reject this training to go
back to safety and away from the dangers
of this
[Applause]
world the final part of Gohan's filler
material concerns this confrontation he
has with the current desires he has and
truthfully the way they went about it I
very much appreciate it discovered by a
commune of Orphans in a deserted Town
Gohan is taken in and alongside This
Crew looks out for each other while
performing dishonest acts in order to
feed themselves the group is led by an
older kid p p pagero i don't
and while it's revealed that Gohan
wishes to go home pigero offers for them
all to join Gohan on his journey back to
mount pazu in a car a car they will
steal through doing so they all get
captured by this Universal version of
Child Protective Services before Gohan
and pigero make their escape Gohan
confused and rather upset at this
suspected betrayal can't understand why
he would do such a thing to his friends
and family in response to this pagero
says that they are already getting into
too much trouble with him that they are
still young and can make something of
themselves this way and with that
tearful send off Goan is sent to run
home now mere yards away from his house
he stops himself looks at his mom
through the window and runs back I love
this conclusion because it's a valuable
lesson for Gohan to learn that sometimes
people are placed in circumstances they
don't understand or enjoy but in the
long run it's for the best and now
running away from his home the place
he's wanted to go since the very
beginning of this filler material he
thinks back to the robot the dinosaur
the kids all the people he couldn't help
and the people he was too weak or
weak-minded to protect or understand
it's at this moment Piccolo confronts
him asking him one question what is your
mission Gohan responds with absolute
certainty to defeat the Sans and save
the Earth what an incredible story I
cannot say the same for the next one
though the saans while I had a lot of
praise for the decisions made around
Gohan fer material I can't say I have
similar sentiments to share for Vegeta's
and nappa's brief escapades on planet
arlia simply because it doesn't Elevate
the kind of material in my book in fact
I would argue it actually gets in the
way of it making it worse where Gohan
story walked us along a compelling tale
of a young man searching for the courage
and confidence to keep fighting the saan
time spent on this alien world only
serves to spoil what was going to be
their introduction on Earth to refresh
your memories when they arrive on Earth
in the manga we are stunned by the scope
of their power and cruelty right off the
bat Napa through his annihilation of an
entire city and Vegeta through his
intelligence and his ruthlessly
cold-hearted approach with the Cybermen
these are compelling moments of
character Revelation and they work
because we value this planet and we
value who they are fighting against but
on Aria we have no idea who these
characters are nor are we really given
much of a reason to care the world is
already a Wasteland and in ruin with the
limited life there acting as hostiles or
captives by the ruling body the elements
of their character are spoke on from the
manga are all used here almost in the
exact same way for Vegeta and Napa but
it's worse the best aspect of this
Saiyan subplot is that it's mercifully
short not even a full episode in length
but even with that it elevates nothing
and in some ways makes what happens
later less effective in my book by
spoiling what the Sands ultimately do
the Earth's forces
another element these Filler episodes
facilitated which I think enriches the
Canon experience during The saian
Invasion has to be this added exposure
we get to the secondary characters
getting to see what yamcha's been up to
with baseball with Bullman how he's
jonesing for a fight again seeing tenens
shinan doing his thing with chsu and
running into launch once again all of
these added scenes offer a sense that
not only are these people Valiant and
ready to fight for Earth but
additionally emphasizes what they will
ultimately be leaving behind their
friends and their loved ones when they
meet their eventual inevitable end
during the Saiyan Invasion it's a nice
place to root their characters before
the Canon material continues onward
furthermore the training we see these
folks undergo is fun if not a little on
the strange side from the outset it's
clear that while they claim that this is
the same room Goku used if you've seen
the room of time before it's clearly not
the same room he used unless they did
some major remodeling since Goku's
Heavenly training alongside Mr Popo that
said I love the lookout so much that
I'll just about take anything I can from
it although brief I'm very much a fan of
what this added exposure offered it
bonds a little more to the characters
before you know they bite the dust later
I think I'm ready to give my score in
this training Arc for the saans but
we've got one stop left Goku and snake
way since I was a little kid watching
this show for the very first time Goku's
adventures in snake way much like the
other prominent favorites in Dragon Ball
Skiller library has remained a personal
favorite of mine and although I haven't
looked at much of it in almost two
decades returning it today only reminded
me of how much I actually loved it for
me my favorite experiences with Goku
come about through his engagement with
other characters and for those like
myself who hadn't seen Dragon Ball as a
kid it's easy to see how Goku started to
feel like a character that would
disappear for a long time interspersed
with brief stints of activity Z starts
and immediately he's dead he runs alone
on snake way he travels to Namek alone
he spends ages in the Rejuvenation tank
alone and once he defeats Frieza he
again disappears and so when I look
things through that lens I think it's
easy to see why I loved snake way it's
not that it offers Goku any meaningful
story advantages like Gohan or The
Supporting Cast received instead it's
just one of a few opportunities we get
in early Dragon Ball Z to exist and have
fun with this character plus it's super
fun the idea that there's a street
cleaner on snake way is a joke so good I
had to mention it in my ultimate review
of the series Goku's falling off snake
way and into hell only to escape and
have to start the pl all over again from
enma's desk was hilarious and the
entanglement he gets into with Princess
snake was beautifully animated with a
fun fish outof water type feel otherw
world is another one of those areas in
Dragon Ball's Mythos that I wish got a
little bit more time spent on it and
this filler material gave me just that I
knew I was going to like the snake way
stuff but outside of the escapades with
Napa and Vegeta I got to say this filler
Arc was very strong as filler goes I
think I have to give it an 8 out of 10
super strong start from Dragon Ball Z
and the next Arc is fake Namek after
that super strong start it's only fair I
get a reality check that confirms how
tiresome this entire Enterprise is going
to be this trip to Namek colloquially
known as the fake Namek Arc is boring
and not because it's filler but because
it's boring everything from how it's
written to how it's presented now
something that was brought to the
Forefront of my mind while watching this
particular batch of Filler episodes is
how substantially role the context you
watch this material play in dictating
your enjoyment for instance when I was a
kid I didn't want to see the training
Gohan underw surviving in the wild prior
to the invasion I wanted to see The
Invasion however because I went into
this video project with the express
mission of watching the Filler episodes
only they no longer were seen as
obstacles to Wade through begrudgingly
by myself but instead they became the
destination and because of that I was
able to enjoy the self-contained story
offered to Gohan in the prior filler
portion however the self-contained story
of the fake neic material is
specifically about how often they can be
delayed under way which isn't Fun the
first two episodes emphasize how long
it's taken to get to where they need to
go it is boring with a capital B in the
first episode nothing happens apart from
them just hitting a roadblock and they
get abducted into the ship nothing
else Krillin and Gohan clean up after
Bulma there's nothing else it's a story
that feels like it only has enough
material for one episode at a stretch
it's just not a fun watch and I didn't
care about the kids on this spaceship
either it does offer some shine to
Frieza and kiwi but it's not necessary
or enjoyable in my opinion the only
conflict is a meteor shower and finally
episodes 3 to 6 the fake Namek episode
is a cute one but even that ends up with
you finding out that this has been a
massive waste of time furthermore
because this is all set up there's once
again no conflict in the first episode
the second episode or really the third
episode finding the Dragon Balls is
relatively easy here and even the cannon
material interspersed within this is
stretched Vegeta is healed almost
immediately in the manga but he's in
this healing tank for ages in these
episodes the idea behind the fake neic
stuff like I said is fine but it goes on
for the length of an average
featurelength film it is far far too
long dragging its feet to an obvious
conclusion that exists purely as an
obacle on root to namic which sucks I
really didn't enjoy these ones it's it's
awful two out of 10 next garlic Jr maybe
this is controversial and I don't know
who needs to hear this out there but the
garlic junor Saga isn't bad it's
actually pretty good I mean turning The
Supporting Cast into demon vampire
zombies is honestly kind of awesome and
if I'm being totally fair in any way
whatsoever let's just say setting it in
the lookout guarantees I love it jokes
aside this is exactly the sort of filler
I look for and I was pretty surprised is
it by its quality when viewed in this
Standalone context this is a story
penned exclusively by one person
katsuyuki Sumi Sawa and that singular
Vision results in a coherent
well-explored story that to me is
actually a lot better than the movie
material that inspired it this isn't
bastardizing a pre-existing idea it's
leveraging our prior understanding and
expectations to create subversions that
are genuinely well executed subversions
that reveal character in beautiful ways
It All Leads leads in quite naturally
from the previous episode where Goku
refuses the wish to bring him back to
Earth it's a time of relative peace and
the AR kicks off by exploring what
exactly Our Heroes actually do during
these brief moments of rest bite for
Gohan it's fetching dinner every day in
a lovely sequence reminiscent of the
opening of The Original Dragon Ball
series for Krillin it's dressing up like
your local pimp and picking up cuties
apparently and for Piccolo well much
like the filler from the Saiyan Saga
he's still an edgy boy beating himself
up in the dark stretches of the
Wilderness probably listening to Hybrid
Theory unre repeat just a guess this
however is where things kick off Kami
himself appears and offers him the role
of Earth's Guardian which of course he
refuses and is a nice reminder of where
he's at mentally prior to the cell arc's
rejoining moment but he also notes that
the moku are on the move again
introducing the man of the hour it's
garlic Jr turns out he escaped The Dead
Zone due to the alignment of the planet
makio that powers up his race how's that
for crazy lore after popo gets his ass
kicked sorry TFS fans Kami rolls up on
the lookout and wow we actually get to
see him fight again I hope you're
starting to see why this Arc might
actually be kind of cool well as it
turns out this spicy gnome wants to take
over the earth once again not exactly a
novel concept but the way he wants to go
about things is what makes this so
interesting in my opinion at least Mr
garlic pours this Aqua mist or the black
water mist from the dub down from the
lookout and starts turning the people
blow into demons this facilitates what I
think is a pretty neat character moment
for Gohan his very own mother and
Friends begin to turn into demons in
front of his very eyes and attack him
and Krillin for a young boy that once
struggled to even leave his father's
side to remain calm and collected in
this moment is honestly awesome to see
it fits in nicely with the development
Gohan saw throughout the Frieza Arc but
as the demon henchmen roll up so too
does Piccolo and The Arc main three are
finally in place with a clear goal beat
garlic Jr and undo the
Transformations well uh there goes one
of the gang at least in a last stage
effort to buy Gohan and Krillin time to
get away Piccolo ends up bitten and what
ensues is one hell of a battle initially
just Gohan versus the henchman things
quickly turn into pupil versus mentor
and eventually Gohan versus mentor and
friend the once crybaby son is forced to
stand alone
against impossible odds what a
captivating idea and
[Music]
yet this is so big brain all this time
Piccolo was pretending and mid battle
convinced Krillin to play along too all
in Aid of rescuing popo and Kami I love
this so much we're so often told that
Piccolo is a smart character but man to
see it in action like this and so
prominently is amazing look at what it
offers the story as a result of this
plan Piccolo had to put all his faith in
Gohan and stand strong in the face of
adversity unaware of his trickery and he
never gives up it's such a perfect
distillation of who these two characters
are two individuals enjoying a pivotal
moment for both of their respective
characters that reveals their underlying
strengths for Gohan it's his courage and
for Piccolo it's his intellect Round of
Applause for Sumi Salwa on this one but
now with the release of Kami and popo
they must head off on their own mini
subplot through the depths of this
strange dimension of the lookout to
retrieve the super holy water the cure
to Garlic's evil minations unfortunately
while this offers some cool visuals it
largely amounts to cutaways of the pair
just running a whole lot of running okay
and some fly too mercifully the battle
against garlic is awesome however the
animation during this section is so good
it's honestly kind of nice to have a
battle set in a location like this given
most of dragon Ball's battles take place
in the wilderness and man does this
battle really reach crazy Heights Gohan
literally impales garlic and this dude
just walks it off due to his immortality
and the crazy power buff from the planet
makio since popo and Kami have succeeded
at this point and the Earth is beginning
to be healed garlic goes crazy and
creates another Dead Zone to try and
suck in the lookout with Piccolo
starting to fade away he gives Gohan one
last big brain move blow up the Planet
buffing him and with one incredible
masenko the planet is obliterated and
with Krillin and Piccolo back in action
the trio send garlic flying back into
the dead zone for good it's such an
awesome teamwork finisher to what has
essentially been side character teamwork
The Arc it really did genuinely surprise
me how much I enjoyed this one garlic Jr
isn't exactly the most interesting
character his henchmen are about as
interesting as paper and the power
scaling doesn't make much sense at all
but that never really got in the way of
what was a fascinating character-driven
tale for me and even its momentary
cutaways to Vegeta are chock full of
interesting commentary I don't know if
it's just because I've never seen it in
Japanese before but this really felt
like an entirely different experience
it's the best of these filler arcs so
far and I urge you to give it another
shot if you're down on it its ambitious
Concepts and fun ideas both narratively
and Visually felt super refreshing and
it did negatively impact the Canon
material in any meaningful way I don't
think I can ask for much more from a
filler episode 88.5 out of 10 great
filler all right time to look at some uh
an Android filler we now move away from
the filler ARs and into Standalone
episodes once again and amusingly these
first two episodes could not be more
different episode 124 might as well be
called the depressed Prince because wo
boy this sad nugget of a man literally
hospitalizes himself trying to become
stronger than Kakarot and while that's
kind of hilarious the episode is
honestly really well directed and a
pretty neat concept All Things
Considered while asleep in the hospital
Vegeta experiences this trippy nightmare
of chasing Kakarot and Trunks only to
find them impossible to reach before his
very eyes they transform into Super
Saiyans and fade off into the distance
as Vegeta screams in anguish over his
inability to reach their level he
remembers his father's words as a child
proclaiming he will one day be the
strongest and even May attain Super
Saiyan the whole thing surprisingly
moving and is undercut and contrasted
with moments of Piccolo Goku and Gohan
training together happily it's the kind
of thing Toriyama would never write this
tortured metaphorical trip through
Vegeta's mind is pretty antithetical to
Dragon Ball's tone entirely but I really
love when filler does this offering
fascinating insight into a character's
mind and contrasting his isolation with
the teamwork the others are using to
improve themselves is super fitting and
I think only adds to the story itself
and on the complete opposite end of the
tonal spectrum is episode 125 the
driving episode
[Music]
a I would love to pretend there's some
sort of lengthy Insight I could provide
for this but it genuinely is just
nonsense wacky Perfection for like 20
minutes straight seeing Goku in civilian
clothes always look so strange to me but
Piccolo manages to pull off the yellow
purple combo hilariously well the whole
thing is a total car crash of an episode
pun absolutely intended and if you
somehow haven't seen it please go check
it out it has got to be the funniest of
all these Filler episodes by a country M
and has solidified itself in the fandoms
memory for good reason I'd give the
first episode a solid 7 out of 10 and
the driving episode is as good as comic
Dragon Ball gets 9.5 out of 10
easy jumping ahead now to the remainder
of the Android arcs filler We Now find
ourselves exploring what the gang is up
to in the gap before the Cell games
begin the first episode in this batch
sees Gohan grope I mean uh save a girl
called lime and while that bizarre gag
might lead you to think this is a
light-hearted affair it's actually a
reasonably serious addition to the story
unfortunately lime's parents were killed
by and now her Village is being overrun
by a tyrant named borbon charging
extortion of prices to let people into
his protective Dome to escape cell's
wrath I honestly really like this as a
concept for a filler episode it's not
often we really get to see the full
extent of how cell's Terror has affected
the Wier World outside of the main
characters both from the perspective of
people who've lost loved ones as well as
the panic and exploitation that takes
place as a result of it this is all
explained to Gohan through the character
of Lao an old man who took in Lime after
her parent parents pasted and who borbon
is extorting for money from the shelter
because apparently charging high prices
to get in isn't enough he's got to rip
off the entire Village to even build it
in the first place and to make matters
worse this ass hat has hired ta pip Pie
as his bodyguard Lao is honestly such a
great character there's a real gravitas
to his screen presence that makes him
feel so effortlessly watchable he's a
classic Master martial artist in every
way and it's awesome to see him take on
the villains of this tale
single-handedly it's an episode where
Gohan doesn't throw a single punch it
truly is the story of the people of this
Village through and through and I kind
of love it for committing to that
Gohan's sole role is really just to
scare ta pipie off as he realizes he's
Goku's son otherwise he largely just
exists as a vessel to push the story
along and Inspire as a result it's hard
to sort of quantify why this episode is
so incredibly good it feels so perfect
for Gohan's pacifist nature all the
while adding to the texture of the
Dragon Ball world it's an 8.5 out of 10
for me it feels like it truly
understands dragon characters and world
and it's another big win for Sumi sawa's
writing would you
believe unfortunately while Gohan
Centric episodes are appreciated episode
171 doesn't really land in the way I
would have liked the concept on paper
sounds interesting enough it's a
birthday party for Gohan and Chi-Chi
spends the time reminiscing about
moments from Gohan's childhood we've
never been privy to before but that's
not really what the episode ends up
being sadly instead we spend much of the
time spinning our wheels on disperate
scenes of Goku riding a fish cell being
bothered by the press or Chi-Chi being
flanderized to unbearable levels while
there are some genuinely Sweet Moments
like the last few minutes of the episode
where the party actually takes place it
sadly doesn't make up for the Meandering
snooze Fest that leads up to that point
I'm regretful 4 out of 10 for this one
thankfully however bright sky is await
in the final episode of the Android
filler
episode 174 is a genuine Delight some
cool scenes with Mr Satan and a sick
trunks training sequence kicks off this
episode making it worthwhile from the
get-go but that's not even what this
episode is about Goku's off searching
for the dragon balls and ends up rolling
in on T pipie and some gangsters in
their secret base what ensues is pure
hilarity it is so good uh Goku doesn't
even seem to register the threat he just
wants the dragon balls they have and
seems to view this whole situation as
some peaceful negotiation which I guess
it it kind of is given to how pip pie is
well it's just so stupid I love this
instead of fighting Goku he gives him a
uh puzzle to complete if he solves it he
gets the Dragon Balls Of course at this
point the mob and to sneak out and drive
off as far as they can only for Goku to
solve it appear next to them and take
the dragon balls again without even
registering they were trying to con him
I don't normally love Goku being
portrayed quite so stupidly but the
sheer naivity being played up in such a
slapstick manner straight up killed me
this is easily a 9 out of 10 and I wish
it was up there with the driving episode
for most fans cuz it's just too good the
Otherworld tournament the Otherworld
tournament or afterlife tournament as
it's Otherwise Known is a strange one
not because it's clearly bizarre or
because it's Dragon Ball Z's only
conventional tournament Arc with a
clear-cut ending no it's strange because
I remember this boring me to tears as a
kid for whatever reason and upon revisit
it's held up considerably well now for
all the other World Tournament fans out
there I'm not trying to suggest that
this Arc is perfect or remotely measures
up to the other Cannon tournaments of
dragon Ball's past it's got its flaws
not the least of which is a distracting
and palpable lack of consequence and
Stakes that is felt throughout the
tournament from beginning to end however
it's that very distinct lack of
consequence and tension that emphasizes
How brave a choice it was to have have a
filler tournament feature so prominently
because fundamentally and structurally I
don't think a filler dragon ball
tournament can be written to meet the
expectations set by its predecessors
tournaments aren't compelling because
they show strong opponents facing off
against other strong Fighters instead
it's the underlying story that takes
place and how that story impacts the
main characters in lasting ways ining
the events of the arcs to come like a
ripple upon a pond set in motion from
the purposeful throw of a pebble but the
uphill battle this Arc faces is that it
doesn't really have a pebble from which
to create interesting ripples nor can it
afford to because there can never be
lasting consequences from a piece of
filler as we've outlined by the arc's
end we need to return to the status quo
other arcs have successfully gotten
around this issue like Gohan's training
under Piccolo where the consequences of
this activity had already been offered
by the Canon material the filler just
filled in the Gap and this is is true
for all the other filler arcs largely
finding safe and comfortable positioning
between two Cannon Moments One offering
a launching pad into the story and
another offering the impending
consequence from which it can draw
inspiration from for example following
Goku's defeat of King Piccolo he seeks
the chage of God to help him prepare for
the 23rd tenai Ichi Budokai against
Piccolo Jr once there it's demonstrated
to us what Goku is lacking this
therefore naturally transitions into a
filler Arch that works towards
establishing the training and lessons he
needs to learn which as I've mentioned
are pointed out later this is to say the
setup and consequences are taken care of
however in this otherw world tournament
there is no setup Beyond Goku looking to
occupy all of this new found time in his
hands and there can't be consequences
because the story We transition into
later doesn't follow Goku or at least
not right away anyway so if I've spent
all of this time talking about the
structural problems with this Arc how
did I have so much more fun than I was
anticip ipating well this might sound
like an unsatisfying answer but it's
just fun while the story is light and
challenged in almost every area Aya
Matsui the sole writer behind this
filler story must have known what she
had to work with as she leaned into its
strengths consistently apart from being
wall to--all funny with Goku Shenanigans
and other worlds check-in station and
airport now acting as a backdrop for
some trademark Dragon Ball humor it's
how this story is framed that I found
quite clever this is dramatic irony the
ark almost every fight in this Arc is
purposely funny and this is to place
emphasis on the fighter that Goku will
inevitably meet in the finals puhan or
Pon in the dub all the while everyone
including those in Goku's own quadrant
doubt his abilities or are put off by
his nonchalant manner of speaking and
presentation doubting his abilities next
to these more traditional Fighters as a
result this my friends is the feedback
loop which fuels Goku's fights in this
tournament one of the kais doubts Goku
and presents him with one of their
Champions only for them to be blown away
by how capable Goku truly is and that
doesn't really get boring as fast as
you'd think for two reasons number one
the gags are on point when Goku's first
opponent put himself into a cocoon only
for him to be DQ due to it taking
thousands of years for him to emerge
that had me rolling around on the floor
laughing this helps the story to feel
less serious and light and number two
the leading reason I think this feedback
loop works for four to five episodes is
because as audience were in on the joke
with Goku and K Kai because we know
something all the other kais and all the
other Fighters don't we know where Goku
came from what he's been through and
most importantly we know what he can do
that's a really powerful feeling for the
audience to experience and with Pan's
fights all being tonally different to
that which Goku and the others have
enjoyed as an audience we look to him as
our white whale to look out for we are
waiting and anticipating puhan the
champion heralded as one of the the best
fighters to have that same exasperated
look in his face when Goku reveals who
he truly is puhan versus Goku this fight
is spread across two episodes and
honestly I'm glad it was because the art
Direction boards and animation of that
first episode was pretty dampening all
things considered in saying that I don't
want to entirely discredit that first
part to their fight and does not without
its own upsides given it's the first
time Goku demonstrates his ability to
transform this is a moment the arc has
purposely been building to the entire
time so much so that they had to quickly
color swap a previous Super Saiyan
transformation in hell to keep it all a
secret this is the moment we've been
waiting for puhan to see and
fantastically he doesn't Flinch or
crumble like the others looking on have
instead he eagerly welcomes The
Challenge and carrying that momentum
into the second and final episode of
this fight were greeted by a massively
improved level of Direction choreography
and animation in this installment in the
back half pan seems to have an answer to
every challenge Goku presents him with
demonstrating in his own way that he's
much faster than even Goku can contend
with this is where our Dynamic with Goku
as an audience member shifts for the
first time and that shift occurs when he
demonstrates a move we haven't seen in a
very long time and in tandem with the
Super Saiyan transformation no less the
kaio-ken used to escape this impressive
move from pan suddenly much like the
audience members we were so excited to
see dumbfounded by Goku's abilities we
are similar L Al sitting there stunned
by what we are seeing it's a cute game
The Ark plays with her perspective and
it's made possible thanks to the move
King Kai taught him specifically which
was a fitting touch in my opinion after
Goku eventually takes this supposed
Victory thanks to a well-timed
Kamehameha used with his Instant
Transmission technique it's revealed
that both competitors feet touched the
outof bounds thus resulting in a double
DQ finish with no side having gained
anything but a different perspective on
each other and that's the strange thing
about this Arc it's ultimately Hollow
and offers little in terms of fleshing
out the existing story like other arcs
have been afforded there are even
arguments one might make that this
filler act should have concerned itself
with Gohan growing up instead of
spending yet more time with Goku a
character we were supposed to be moving
away from but despite all of that it's
still a ton of fun for all the reasons
I've outlined I don't think it'll leave
a lasting impression on me and like I
said it has its flaws but overall it's a
much more enjoyable experience than I
recalled 6.5 out of 10
the boar and now we hit the point where
the anime had a substantial overhaul new
series director new character designer
the works and well the approach to
filler completely changed too up until
this point there have been some pretty
chunky stretches of dedicated filler
arcs and Standalone episodes but those
mostly just melt away in this Arc and
instead they're replaced with
fully-fledged extensions of the cannon
material now don't get me wrong I'm not
about to pretend the previous arcs
didn't drag out fights with extended
battles and staredowns or cutaways to
non-combatants doing all sorts of silly
stuff here's looking at you ginu frog
but that's not what I mean here those
absolutely exist but the way the filler
works here is deeply ingrained into the
story it shows what was unseen in the
manga or extends it dramatically in some
cases it even replaces Canon material
with its own take on things it's how an
arc that is seven volumes long in the
manga around the same length as Frieza
and cell individually ended up
encompassing a little under half of the
entire series for example take Gohan
cmen identity being unraveled by Videl
in the manga Gohan zooms off in Disguise
after Videl to Aid in the takedown of
some bank robbers the whole thing's over
in only a few pages and Videl catches
the great Sean out by using Gohan's name
and getting him to respond it's all
hilariously stupid in that iconic prama
sort of way and wraps up super quick by
Videl essentially going uh my guy you
literally have Gohan's voice voice and
knew my name are you dumb it's honestly
incredible the anime on the other hand
replaces this segment with a bunch of
robbers hijacking a senior citizen
sightseing bus it is so beyond absurd
the old people on the bus don't even
realize what's going on and start
wondering what the tour will show them
next there are helicopter jumps the bus
shoots off a cliff it is crazy with a
Capital C after the great San flies in
to rescue the bus he accidentally uses
videl's name to which she wonders how he
knew her name and then the episode just
uh it ends What's Happening Here is that
the anime is essentially breaking down
Gohan's mistakes into individual
episodes in the very next episode Gohan
slips up and lands on the school roof as
the great s man before dropping the
disguise only to notice that a classmate
called Angela had seen him what follows
is Angela bizarrely blackmailing Gohan
to go on a date with her they go to the
movies to a coffee shop and all the
while Gohan keeps messing up as cursed
as this sounds it's honestly pretty damn
hilarious but I think my favorite moment
is probably where Gohan goes to ask
Chi-Chi for advice and she reminisces
about her first date with Goku I mean
little boy Goku had no clue what a date
was and upon chii explaining it was the
most fun thing you could think of my
little man throws a right hook it is
perfection unfortunately the episode
kind of spins its Wheels by repeating
the same plot point from the last
episode Danger's around videl's in the
scene and Gohan has to jump in and Well
turns out the secret Angela knew all
along was that Gohan where teddy bear
Underpants and she saw nothing on the
roof because she had no contacts in and
it just keeps going like this the next
episode once again has the same plot
Point trouble occurs Videl is there
Gohan steps in rinse and repeat the
final episode at least includes a plot
point that pulls on my animal loving
heartstrings with a circus abusing a
dinosaur but like this is still
fundamentally the exact same structure
for the fourth episode in a row four
episodes of content a whole movie's
worth of runtime for or something that
was essentially a gag for a few pages in
the manga there's some great comedy in
spots but unfortunately four episodes
just nukes the pacing and kind of
murders the idea that Videl is a Smart
Cookie I'd probably give this segment uh
four out of 10 it has its moments but
boy is a slog at times Goku versus Majin
Vegeta for many this doesn't even
register as filler and it's easy to see
why I mean it's one of the most highly
anticipated rematches in the series and
in the manga it amounts to a quick pager
to of flurries and then it ends it is
Chuck full of fantastic dialogue
absolutely but it is not a fight really
and while it's easy to argue that that's
the point and maybe I'd agree I think
this is one aspect this adaptation
really excels in all the battles in this
Arc just feel huge the various animation
staff involved in this particular bout
truly gave it their all it is full of
iconic sequence after iconic sequence
that just bills and bills across several
episodes I think it works super well
well from the angle of fan service but
also in the sense of adding real weight
to the power that ultimately gives rise
to Majin Buu while I can definitely see
arguments against extending this to such
an extent personally I just think the
entertainment Factor outweighs it
entirely it's got to be at a minimum a 9
out of 10 the animation is just too good
and the tension so palpable that it
might as well just be the de facto
version of events and now it's time for
the awkward bits now this is where it
starts to get kind of hard to throw
titles up you see the filler genuinely
becomes so so completely sporadic and
ingrained in the content that it's
almost impossible to talk about it
individually without this video being
like 9 hours long which hey you might
enjoy but I value sleep so how about a
quick fire round episode 239 RI does
horrible things to Android 18 while
Bulma and viell take on a suspiciously
well animated dinosaur it's a pretty
looking episode but it offers very
little outside of video evidence that
roshi should be in jail episode uh well
basically all the episodes for the time
being Bo who turns people into candy and
terrorizes the city over and over and
over and over and over and oh just make
it end episode 251 Gotenks is born and
immediately goes to fight Buu this is
offscreen in the manga because it's
literally a gag about his Cockiness the
anime shows it it undermines the whole
gag it's not even a good fight episode
252 Mr Satan becomes Buu's best buddy
this episode is basically the entire
concept from the manga stretched out
into almost a full episode and it is
glorious
I mean it actually animates the Mr Satan
video game great extension no complaints
here episodes 256 and 257 why did we
need two episodes of Buu walking around
the lookout Why
episode go tank stuff this time chamber
fight is super drawn out and all the
cutaways are just Gohan sat still
waiting I mean I like go tanks but not
for four episodes straight of the exact
same stuff but hey like I mentioned in
my review of this AR I do love the
reaction to him learning that his family
is now gone hooray for sadness episode
Vegito stuff did you know that Vegito
only lasts for two chapters in the manga
well you get him for four episodes in
the anime wow four episodes this show
really loves four episodes of things
well maybe it's hypocritical to say but
four episodes of Vegito are way cooler
than four episodes of Gotenks you know
what else lasts for four episodes though
the inside of Boo there's actually a
fully dedicated section of filler here
that was originally just a single
chapter in the manga and while most of
it is mind numbingly dull episode 274
has the gang battling Phantom versions
of their kids and it's kind of awesome
what follows are mostly just battle
extensions that thankfully are pretty
sick too the added content to the fight
in the kaioshin realm produced one of
the best looking episodes in the series
episode 279 and that's true for a lot of
the fights in the climax here also the
anime really turns things up to 11 and
produces extended content that adds some
awesome weight to the show's final
battle but well I'd be remissed to not
mention the insane cutaway to ghost arra
hanging out with the ghost girlies it
kills the pacing but I won't lie it is
pretty funny and hey who doesn't love
watching s and Frieza standing there
salty as all hell in hell and well that
brings a close to the quick fire round
as we now jump into the final dedicated
filler episode of Dragon Ball Z's entire
run episode
288 this final piece of fully original
content sees the gang throwing a party
which apparently they love to do given
that this is also the premise of Yos Son
Goku and his friends return special and
Battle of Gods and you know what maybe
that's the key to good Dragon Ball
content because this episode is pretty
fire there's something just so sweet and
wholesome about Chi-Chi picking out what
she needs to wear while Gohan and Goten
get dressed it's a rare bit of normality
we don't often get a glimpse of and the
fact that this is all happening while
Goku is off out poking around in nature
just feels so in keeping with his
character and a nice throwback to the
early days of his life and well I think
that's the point Point Goku sits and
reminisces about how this is the very
Mountain grandpa Gohan found him on all
those years ago he reflects on how his
grandpa may have been strict but he was
also super kind it even shows him being
given the iconic Yoo allowing this
section to all feel like a perfect way
to reflect back on what has been an
incredibly long journey not just for the
characters but for the people who
watched the show on the air at the time
as the party rages on there are so many
adorable interactions like Bulma
barbecuing tens shinan giving and pizza
Majin Buu trying to take Vegeta's food
and Vegeta actually agreeing I mean it's
all just so lovable and of course gave
rise to the absolutely iconic disco ball
z
moment while the second half gets a
little tiring seeing the dinosaur plot
continue once again I mean it's it's
sort of important I I think uh Goku
finally arrives and tells the gang the
story of how he saved the dinosaur
babies and it sort of feels symbolic for
him fostering in a new generation a
pivotal theme of the series's finale
what follows is Goku joking about being
dead when Goten was born before Goku
kindly welcomes Vegeta to stop standing
by himself and well I think when
combined with the Beautiful music and
the narrator celebrating Sun Goku's
charm it's a perfect way to wrap up this
era as the show heads into its time Skip
and eventually the end of the series 7.5
out of 10 it's pretty cute Dragon Ball
Z's filler gets a bad rep and it's not
exactly surprising given some of the
content I've outlined today a lot of the
series features mind numbing extensions
of content that was meant to be short or
cutaways to content that disrupts the
flow and pacing of certain stretches the
stuff can be brutal and it certainly
sticks with people given it's sort of
being exaggerated in people's minds to
the point that they think characters
genuinely power up for multiple episodes
at a time now but I think what's become
clear for me these past two videos is
that there's actually a lot to love
about Dragon Ball's dedicated filler
material especially in the context in
which I've just viewed it in you see for
most people filler is something that
gets in the way it's a blockade of sorts
to the next point in the story whether
that be Nine episodes of training before
Napa and Vegeta arrive or 10 episodes of
garlic Jr while you wait for the Android
Arc to begin it's pretty hard to find
much enjoyment in disruption but as I've
sat down and watched many of these
self-contained arcs and episodes in
isolation I found that they work
surprisingly well that way especially
those arcs conceived of and written by a
single person I'm enjoying so much of
what they have to offer the characters
and the world on their own even if I
know that when placed in context They
don't serve the narrative pacing in the
best of ways I do however think that
that's definitely the right move for
shows that need filler so as not to
catch up with the manga rather than Pat
out Canon material to the point it hurts
the story and tortures the viewers
instead create meaningful arcs between
content like Dragon Ball did it has the
benefit of being able to be skipped over
without issue once a show is done airing
and it offers great Standalone viewing
for those who want to watch it at a
later date it helps your series stand
the test of time better I think think
even if it has historically come at the
cost of poor ratings the main reason
many shows nowadays don't take this
approach but what kind of content do you
prefer are you with me on this one or
would you rather stick with Canon
content even if it comes to the cost of
being slower than intended let me know
down in the comment section below and
thanks so much for joining me on this
Bizarro detour through Dragon Ball Z's
filler it's been a long old journey
through Dragon Ball over the past few
months and I am more than ready to jump
into something new so be sure to stay
tuned as next week we're diving into a
special new
[Music]
series